ce que je n'ai jamais entendu, c'est que tu es
parfait comme tu étais, il y a juste
ce genre de pression tacite pour
participer à une fête avec des personnes beaucoup plus âgées
et si je ne le faisais pas, je ne
travaillerais pas autant, alors j'ai remarqué un  modèle que
quand je tu sais que quand j'allais à des
dîners quand je traînais avec des
gens puissants qui étaient en charge de réserver mes
contrats je travaillais plus je me sentais sous pression
que si je ne couchais pas avec mon patron ou
si je ne le faisais pas si  Je ne me suis pas comporté d'une
certaine manière que je n'allais pas obtenir de
gros contrats et c'était mon seul
travail, alors parfois que faites-vous dans ces
situations
[Musique]
il s'agit de bien
paraître et et même je suis gentil  de sceptique
parce que j'ai l'impression que même ces
campagnes sur la diversité corporelle sont géniales, mais je
suis tellement consciente du moment où vous êtes
mannequin et que vous allez dans votre agence,
elles sont toujours très strictes, vous savez,
et elles vous diront n'importe quoi, alors je  on
m'a tout dit de vous savez allez faire
une chirurgie plastique ce que j'ai fait parce que je
Je voulais travailler correctement un jour, littéralement, ils me mesuraient pour un
travail et me disaient que tu étais trop gros ou que tes
jambes étaient trop grosses, puis le lendemain,
ils diraient wow tu as perdu tellement de
poids alors tu sais ce qui se passe
ici alors j'ai eu l'impression que je n'étais jamais dans le
bon chemin et quand tu n'es pas stable mentalement,
c'est très dommageable
plus
beau que j'étais parfait alors j'ai
pensé bien attends une minute je me sens malade
je sais que je ne vais pas bien tu sais
je vomis j'avais mes cheveux qui
tombaient tu sais et mon cœur ne bat pas
correctement tu sais que tu pourrais  vois tous mes
os mais pourtant tu me dis que je suis
belle alors pourquoi c'est pourquoi c'est seulement
que quand je ne suis rien tu penses que je suis
quelque chose que je connais en France tu as fait passer
une loi qui est très importante n'est-
ce pas et c'est comme  chaque fois que vous avez une
culture négative, cela demande beaucoup de travail,
donc c'est peu  e pas et petits pas ça
fait de grandes victoires